eh what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is Apple's new flagship phone for
the next year the iPhone 6 so there's a
new design this year for Apple's
flagship and of course the theme here is
thin and light this phone is six point
nine millimeters thin and it's all one
piece of aluminum rounded off at the
corners so instead of having the squared
off edges like the last iPhone Apple's
rounded off the sides the phone feels a
lot more like the HTC One m8 now and
this has two effects the first is that
it gives the whole body this seamless
feel if you start your finger on the
screen and drag it all the way around to
the back of the phone you won't
encounter any seams it's just one smooth
surface but two is that since it's so
smooth it's actually a bit slippery to
hold plus it's a little bigger and it's
so light that my confidence actually
holding and manipulating this foam in
the hand is dropping every time but part
of me wants to put a case on it but you
guys know how I feel about cases so a
high quality skin will suit me just fine
and of course D brand has a couple of
badass skins for the iPhone 6 to help
out this grip ability so I'll leave
links to those right below the like
button if you want to check those out
highly recommended but the rest of the
build of this phone is definitely
awesome it's a bit bigger than the last
iPhone but I think it's a much better
size now and you only take a few minutes
to get used to it before you look back
at the iPhone 5s and it starts to look
like a toy it's obviously a bit bigger
than other phones with a 4.7 inch
display since this one has a big little
chin for the home button and a big
forehead to match but what's more
striking than his size is I think the
thinness again 6.9 millimeters that is
crazy thin almost feels too thin and
light to be a working phone it feels
almost the same weight as the dummy
phone it's so thin in fact the camera
lens on the back protrudes out a bit now
this turns out to be not a huge deal
since it's coated in sapphire anyway and
it just rocks a bit when it's placed on
a flat surface but that's minor so this
is the first iPhone to move the power
button from the top to the side of the
phone and that's good that's what other
bigger phones have been doing for years
and that's much easier to reach and also
it has a physical mute switch and I
think that's a nice touch most
don't do this yet but sometimes got
switched off in my pocket every once in
a while but I like the physical mute
button so I have a few mixed feelings
overall about the build of the phone
since it's so razor thin but it's
definitely built well it shouldn't bend
in your pocket or anything actually I
think the worst quirk about the hardware
is the speaker on the bottom it's a
pretty loud speaker I mean it's got
decent mids and highs and it's a little
bit tinny but the thing is it's a small
downward facing driver so it's really
easy to accidentally block it when
you're holding the phone watching a
video or playing a game now I know that
often in the room right now is the
iPhone 6 plus which is the companion'
5.5 inch iPhone that Apple released
alongside the iPhone 6 a couple of weeks
ago and basically my opinion on that is
this day I'm gonna review it separately
in a completely different video and
that's upcoming but if you're trying to
decide between the 6 and the 6 plus
consider this all of the factors that
make the iPhone 6 a little bit slippery
and a little bit difficult to hold in
the hand or amplified on the iPhone 6
plus it's an even bigger phone in every
single way and it's still rounded on the
edges so it's even more difficult to
grip the easiest way to see this is to
go into an Apple store and hold one but
trust me the 6 plus is huge so really
besides improved internals the main
physical advantage to this iPhone 6 over
an older iPhone is the size it's a
bigger screen and it has all the
advantages that naturally come with
having that bigger screen so bigger
icons bigger UI bigger text bigger web
browsing bigger gaming bigger video
watching bigger keyboard but what's
funny is it stops there so the iPhone 6
has a 4.7 inch 1334 by 750 IPS display
with awesome colors and great brightness
and incredible viewing angles and a
pretty high pixel density 326 PPI makes
it the same as the iPhone 5 and 5s and
iOS 8 is trained to take advantage of
every inch of this display by basically
scaling everything up from the iPhone 5s
but like I said there aren't really any
extra features in iOS to take advantage
of the larger display so there aren't no
multitasking features or anything extra
there is apples interestingly
implemented reach ability which is
basically to make one-handed use easier
so you can double touch the home button
to move the UI halfway down
the display so you can interact with the
top half of stuff I sometimes use this
to reach those top corner buttons and
apps or pull down the notification bar
when I'm feeling lazy but yeah that's
about it as far as apples extra features
for a big screen go again it's a great
display I just I guess I wish they just
did more to take advantage of it maybe
show more apps in the multitasking menu
make touch targets bigger and
first-party apps things like that they
don't have to force anything but I just
wish they'd been more with all those
extra pixels but the rest of iOS 8 is
very familiar to anyone who's ever used
an iPhone or an iPad before I really
don't have to explain that you have some
improvements to the notification area so
now you can add widgets just to the
notification area that's stay there and
permanently show information so you can
get more apps from the App Store to fill
up this panel with different widgets
that show info and you can you can kind
of mess around with these and get
shortcuts and real-time stats and info
and stuff and that's nice but you can
only have them like I said in this today
section or notification panel but
overall you have a nice layer of gloss
over the top of a very familiar user
interface it's pretty DUP with this
gloss and reflections all over the place
I still like iOS a lot even though it's
a bit restricted in terms of where I can
share too and how I can get into Google
services but it seems like every new
version there's a flash of something
that makes the OS a little more
appealing
speaking of flash there's a highlight of
the new iPhone and that is the camera on
the back actually the camera is always a
highlight of the new iPhone but that
doesn't mean we should take it for
granted the iPhone 6 has a great camera
one of the best and one of the fastest
in any smartphone I think that's a key
word here towards making the camera so
great it's extremely fast so use your
interface is fast taking a picture is
really really fast it can take high
frame rate fast video at 30 60 or 720p
even 240 frames per second it has fast
autofocus with this new technology it
has a fast wide open aperture glass for
great low-light performance and now it's
still an 8 megapixel camera but on that
130 inch sensor it's kind of like a
hybrid between HTC's massive ultra
pixels and Samsung's cramming as many
pixels as possible mentalities maybe
this is the middle ground that we were
asking HTC to
all along all the photos it takes are
very clean the camera tends to have a
bias towards a faster shutter speed kind
of like the oneplus one to avoid
blurriness so it's willing to crank up
the ISO and just trust its top-notch
image processing to clean things up and
that's really where it's separated it
has great image processing and this does
a pretty good job of cleaning up noise
which makes some crispy clean shots with
excellent color the only downside of
this camera I would say is the fact that
it's only 8 megapixels which means no 4k
video 4k is actually 8.3 megapixels so
this 8 megapixel sensor means this
iPhone will not shoot 4k video until the
next one
so overall like I said before this whole
phone is a very familiar phone a safe
upgrade for previous iPhone users for
sure if you just straight-up look at the
numbers you'll see a 1.4 gigahertz
dual-core chip and one gig of ram but
the thing performs like any other phone
with a 2.5 gigahertz chip and three gigs
of ram so you can bank apples vertical
integration and the awesome a8 chip for
that so with the iPhone 6 you're getting
a great performer a great camera a great
display and a great design all in a
super thin package so with a super thin
phone you also get a super thin battery
so the iPhone 6 is rocking a 1810
milliamp hour battery on paper that's
really small and you might consider that
super small by other phone standards by
Android phone standards by other
flagship standards by other 4.7 inch
phone standards but Apple has the
advantage of at least it owns that AAA
chip it has iOS under control everything
is optimized to give it the longest
battery life possible so I would
summarize by saying it has but about 10
to 15 percent better battery life than
the iPhone 5s it's not amazingly great
but it's not bad it has the advantage of
having a really good standby time so if
you don't use it a lot during the day or
if you have a light usage day you'll
probably make it throughout the day not
having any problems you can go to sleep
with 100% battery forget to charge it
and wake up with 98% so that's great but
on a heavy day if you're doing a lot of
web browsing a lot of photo and video
taking a lot of video watching a lot of
gaming if you're doing a lot of stuff
where the screen on time is high during
that day you're probably not going to
make it to the end of the day
and you're gonna have to go find a
charger before the day is out this is
not different from the iPhone 5s this is
just something that comes with having a
small thin phone and apples totally fine
with making that sacrifice I just wish
the phone was a little bit thicker so
they could fit maybe a 2000 or 2100
milliamp hour battery and that would
make the phone yes a little bigger at
but it would get rid of the camera
protrusion and might make it a little
bit easier to hold but that's all stuff
I've said before but look there's one
more thing
iOS isn't perfect there are hiccups
sometimes there are bugs sometimes there
was that 8.1 update that freakin bricked
the phone but they quickly fix that but
this is the first time in a while that
I've seen a significant lag in major
developers getting their apps updated to
iOS 8 on this bigger iPhone especially
the 6 and the 6 plus apps that haven't
been updated for this larger display
look big and awkward and fuzzy and
strange and I hope devs get on that to
fix their apps and then and only then I
will have basically nothing except the
battery to complain about in the iPhone
6 so solid phone apple so my overall
final verdict obviously as a heavy
Google service user Google+ user a
YouTube user a gmail user Google Tasks
Google keep Google Calendar all these
things iOS 8 and iPhones aren't my first
choice obviously but my choice of iPhone
is also not the iPhone 6 it's the iPhone
6 plus and I'll be talking more about
why the iPhone 6 plus is my iPhone of
choice in that full review video but for
right now the iPhone 6 is a safe step
forward it's a it's a definite upgrade
from the last iPhone but like I said not
a mandatory upgrade so stay tuned for
that 6 plus review video and many more
forward videos to come thank you for
watching this one and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace